hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
brain-tumor exosomes in cancer immunity
that Baltar's immune confusion presented
by Michael Greiner he is an associate
professor of Neurosurgery of the
University of Colorado Denver
I am Marjorie Torrez the lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational racial events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you're reviewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and best offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Michael Greger I will now turn the
presentation over to him ok good day
everyone I'm Michael Greiner as you've
just been told I'm at the University of
Colorado Denver the Anschutz medical
campus and although I'm in neurosurgery
I'm not a neurosurgeon I just kind of do
the science behind it I've been asked to
discuss cancer immunity relative to
things called exosomes these are little
fat balls that gets spit outside of
cells in one way or another
so we'll move along and talk about that
first I need to declare declare my
disclosures I have nothing to talk about
you will see a number of cats and dogs
throughout this performance how did I
get into this as a frequent question and
it includes basically my real science
career began
I left the world of Drosophila and moved
into pediatric oncology which is a
perfectly logical progression there I
worked in a laboratory where we were
developing cancer vaccines and these
were heat shock protein based cancer
vaccines so those heat shock proteins
are stress protein so you would have
thought that we would have studied
stress responses ahead of time but we
didn't instead we went right to the the
stress proteins themselves however as I
moved on in my life I started studying
the actual stress responses and that is
where we came across the idea and then
in the presence of things called
extracellular vesicles or exosomes and
in theory we were the first people to
describe these in brain tumors and it
came from basically stress in cells well
that led back to the idea that we could
look into the immune responses to them
because we were kind of a vaccine lab
and later on we learned that those
particular stress stress cells could
also turn into spit out exosomes or
extracellular vesicles that could be
immune suppressants so this the story
has be kind of swinging in multiple
directions so going from vaccines to
immunotherapy to cancer me and
suppression that will all be sort of
discussed in the context of today's talk
so the problem that I work on is the
brain tumor this was the worst ones are
called glioblastoma and they are they're
pretty nasty buggers the median survival
for patients is only 15 months and the
quality of life can be pretty poor
everything you see here is the problem
with a brain tumor the there's a very
heterogeneous batch of cells in there
that's obviously quite proliferative
it's invasive across the corpus callosum
which is the middle of the brain slice
you see there that's kind of a no-go for
surgery and you'll also see that there
are intense areas of bloodiness so
they're very vascular they're also very
hypoxic and obviously in the end since
we're looking at this slide things were
badly for this patient they're actually
very resistant to therapy there are
number of reasons for that one is
molecular and some of it is just plain
physical the idea that this is in the
brain and the blood-brain barrier is a
major into the intent
to getting drugs up there I should point
out that surgically and chemo radiation
are pretty much only standard of care
therapy is right now so we're focusing a
lot on experimental therapies to try to
improve this completely abysmal outcome
now what I'm going to talk about today
may be somewhat particular to brain
tumors but in general it's going to
apply to most other cancers as well so
moving on those things those
extracellular vesicles those stat balls
this is a gorgeous slide that I of
course drawn myself that kind of covers
everything that I hope we can get out of
the story I'm going to be looking at
essentially two portions of this one is
going to be what we call change my thing
here the the exosomes and those are
going to come from the Indus eye ptosis
of cell surface molecules and the
entrapment of cytosolic proteins within
those those endosomes so that's what
you're following here is as proteins on
the surface are engulfed into the cell
by an Indesit ik mechanism and pick
whatever mechanism you want they will
end up in these early endosomes those
early endosomes then mature to later
endosomes but what happens during that
period is you get this bleeding this
internal bleeding that occurs that picks
up pieces of cytosol so proteins and
RNAs that are in the cytosol will now
get taken in to these vesicles and these
but off completely to the inside where
you have small little vesicles inside a
larger vesicle at this stage the thing
is called a multi vesicular body and the
little things inside it are called intra
and Inter lumenal vesicles or
intravascular bodies as well notice we
can't have one name for this stuff we
have to have multiple names for them the
canonical fate of an MDB
is to go to the lysosome and be degraded
and have the contents of sort of
recycled but we know that under some
conditions these vesicles will actually
end up fusing with the plasma membrane
and that's get another thing to draw
here right here for instance so what
that does
as it releases the little vesicles from
the inside to the outside of the cell
and now we call those X's ohms and that
is the the official designation from for
them other means of having this occur is
when things will split off try to get a
change of this will split off the cell
surface directly they'll bud off like
that and they're called micro vesicles
or exosomes or sometimes shed vesicles
notice we can't have a single name for
anything we have to have multiple names
and nobody agrees on these things so the
point that you're I want to make from
this is that in general these are they
look like the cell itself they've got a
rough recapitulation of the the outer
membrane and the inner membrane proteins
that were sticking out of the cell
membrane are going to be sticking out of
the vesicle membrane and proteins and
RNAs that are inside the cell will end
up inside the vesicles so there's there
sort of a recapitulation of what the
cell looks like in a very tiny scale so
we think of them as means of
intercellular communication since they
can leave the cell and instead of having
self cell contact you can now have cell
decimal contact so the vesicle leaves
the cell and goes and bumps into another
cell and transfers information to it now
these were originally discovered by Phil
Stahl and Rolf Rose Johnstone they're
the ones credited for giving them the
names exosomes
and it was as a form of disposal the
idea that as reticulocytes were maturing
to red blood cells they had to get rid
of things like the transferrin receptor
after losing their license ohms so
that's was the the idea was these are
essentially garbage bags that's not a
very sexy concept except when you're
living in a place where they don't pick
up the garbage and you understand how
important that is we have studied a lot
of the effects of signaling nests of
other groups the idea being that the
vesicles can carry signaling molecules
themselves that can be delivered to
recipient cells but they can also prompt
changes in signaling on those recipient
cells and one of the big areas that's
come out lately is the idea of RNAs that
are inside these exosomes or
extracellular vesicles being transferred
almost in a viral like fashion to
recipient cells and speaking of viruses
figured out this pathway long before we
did so viruses really understand how to
hijack the system and take off as do a
number of other pathogens they're way
ahead of us in terms of how we study
these I'm just trying to make this go
forward and so there are my drawings
there's other people's drawings so this
is pieces and much-improved artwork over
time so we see for instance here
extracellular vesicles moving towards
the inside the multi particular body's
being released outside essentially a
farting mechanism over here it looks
like a zit being popped as these things
are squeezed out and here we see the the
the bag of worms version of this so
these are extremely crowded very heavily
laden little balls or tiny little fat
balls and as we would have noticed not
all of us Kathy got the message about
the artwork I promise it's the last time
you'll see that slide so one other form
of extracellular vesicle that I didn't
mention but we don't talk too much about
them are the a photonic bodies so I've
described the exosomes
coming through the end result and the
zonal system the micro vesicles that pop
off the cell surface and we've included
in the term extracellular vesicles the
idea of a photonic bodies so as the cell
sort of degenerates it will release
these things they're usually considered
to be pieces of material that are taken
up by the neighboring cells but it turns
out they have some pretty very
interesting capacities as far as also
signaling and talking to those cells but
we're not going to discuss those other
critters make these things as well so
single-celled organisms will make
exosomes and plasma membrane blebs that
are essentially the same thing as micro
vesicles and gram-negative bacteria make
outer membrane vesicles so I've got to
point those out I also need to point out
this particular review article because
I'm one of sixty authors on it very
proud of that
the idea though I want you to make sure
you get is that cells don't release
simply one kind of vesicle so we need to
repair in mind that they're going to be
multiple spheres of multiple sizes and
multiple origins floating out of a given
cell at any time and as far as we know
all cells make these things they give
you some idea of how big they are
or how small they are now here's a nice
slide from a review article and it puts
them in the context of things you
probably recognize you may have heard of
such as bacteria platelets protein
aggregates and the exosomes which are
the ones I'll mostly be talking about or
on the sizes of virus size viruses and
so this is the the appreciation of
dimension it's not a terribly accurate
of appreciation of dimension it's more
like this so we're starting to talk
about the the different sizes of
vesicles that can come out of the cells
this is relatively what they tend to
look like so I'll be speaking mostly of
the exosomes down here which are like I
said on the size of viruses um as far as
those dimensions go the literature is
sort of replete with different terms
that people have used mostly depending
on who's reviewing your article so we've
commonly said they're 3,200 nanometers
in diameter
once again size of the viruses I've seen
in the literature these numbers changing
going up over time and I think it's
because people don't really know what
they're talking about so when you get to
the size of about 300 nanometers you're
starting to say talk about something
between two actually still the multi too
sick of my body so it's probably not a
true exosome so we focus on these 30 to
100 nanometers as it's sort of the
classical size what does that mean in
terms of a volume I had a student sort
of delve into this he came up with the
term yok to leaders and he didn't invent
that term it's real I've never heard of
such a thing but it's about ten to the
minus twenty fourth liters so it's
pretty tiny
but once again because it's there about
the size of viruses suggests that they
could hold about packed tightly a
hundred proteins and sort of 10,000
nucleotides worth of stuff nucleic acid
just to give you some idea of how much
stuff is in these things and what we do
about that so in other words are packed
pretty tightly and we now know from some
of our or some of the really good
cryo-electron microscopy work that's
going out there that these don't
necessarily have to be round we always
drawn this round but they don't
necessarily have to be and also things
will flop out over the sides and those
are very important because those are
probably ways that they talk to other
cells in terms of either bouncing off
and we're being taken up by them
so what's inside and on the outside of
the exosomes really matters so as far as
the contents of a nexus ohm go this is
sort of a standard view of it and I'm
just going to highlight some of the
things that we almost always see in them
some proteomic analysis we almost always
see metabolic enzymes we almost always
see in Exxon's we almost always see heat
shock proteins very typical stuff also
the tetris span ins are sort of our
method for identifying these pick a pick
a CD something CD 9 CD 81 CD 63 all of
these are regarded as Tetris Panna and
type markers for these extracellular
vesicles we also always find intra
presumably within the vesicles actin and
tubulin that we assume is monomeric
because there's not a lot of room for
polymerized particles to be in there so
that's probably one of the issues we
would ask is they most of the proteins
that get in seem to have been in the
form of complexes but oftentimes those
complexes are too big to actually get in
the cell we also see the RAB GTP aces
those are sort of classically another
way to define these now depending on
where the exosome came from what cell
type released it we may see different
types of receptors we may see different
types of adhesion molecules you may see
if tgf-beta we also may see major
histocompatibility complex molecules
because those are produced by most every
cell serum proteins are often regarded
as contaminants because they cling to
these things but biology doesn't really
like the idea of the contaminant so
these are probably really probably
belong there the types of lipids we see
in them are usually structure forming
because these things have to bend very
tightly and it takes a fair amount of
energy to do that so you're going to
have structure forming lipids as well as
bioactive lipids so that's a rapid
overview of the protein content now the
RNA content I'll get into a little bit
later any kind of RNA you can think of
pretty much shows up in these things
which means they're turns out to be our
RNA binding proteins robbing nuclear
proteins rival nuclear particles that
associate with them as well and those
single-stranded and double stranded DNA
have been found in them also so which
when you think about that if you're able
to isolate these vesicles you might be
able to determine the same mutated state
of a person or though their of their
cancer so to speak based on the DNA you
may find in them or even the RNA you
find in them I'll talk a little bit more
about that later so when we got into
this we've done a lot of proteomic work
and we were noticing as I mentioned the
number of nucleic acid binding proteins
and that probably does too think that we
needed a larger cat's eye view of this
situation to see well what what sort of
proteins have been identified in these
and fortunately for us there is a
database called vesicle pedia that
houses pretty much everything we know
about the protein contents of these of
these vesicles and when we sifted
through that to get rid of all the
duplicate entries and and just identify
proteins we could come up with that were
human the reason we used Humanist so we
could use them and downstream sort of
analyses that are more prone to human
studies than anything else
we ourselves came up a little over 3,000
proteins and this is just a table
showing you some of the work we did with
that a much better job was done by these
guys by yeongsu's group at young young
songs group and in Korea they identified
around 4000 proteins the 13,000 vesicle
proteins total but of those about 7,000
are found in humans and of those about
4,000 or those most prevalent so we're
looking at a subset of the other
proteome in terms of how many genes and
how many proteins could possibly be in
there it doesn't seem like everybody
gets in but there there tend to be some
sort of selection methods we don't
really understand what those are one of
the other really important components of
these vesicles are the lipids obviously
I'm kind of wound up about those because
it's necessary for these lipids to work
to fold and bend this thing into this
very tight structure among those you
will find the structure forming things
such as ceramides and cholesterol the
reason we don't have a great concept
does what the lipids are is because
those technologies for identifying them
are far behind what we have for say
the the nucleic acids of the protein so
that just the the the databases aren't
there the techniques aren't there the
libraries aren't there but they're
growing one thing to imagine about that
is you'll have a particular head group
of a lipid that can have multiple or
different chain links tail links on it
and those can be mostly saturated so you
can imagine trying to do mass
spectrometry on that becomes pretty
difficult when you've got so many
variables in potentially the same
molecule so I'm not going to talk too
much more about that but I will say that
these lipids are somewhat specific for
the vesicles there there are
distinctions between what gets into the
vesicles and what is coming out of the
cell like I sort of acted like it's the
exact same thing but there is a
selection for that one thing we've
delved into and this is slowly becoming
more and more popular is the use of
metabolomics on these which enables you
to identify not just say lipids but also
sorts of aqueous molecules as well this
is just some work we've done the one
thing that I found interesting about
that is that we can distinguish between
the metabolome x' so to speak of cells
versus the exosomes using principal
component analysis so there is something
distinct about what gets in these as
cargo not only as proteins and lipids
but also as other types of metabolic
phenomenon so we're still pursuing that
and lots of other people are too now to
the RNA world about 2007 Yamla falls
group identified RNAs in in
extracellular vesicles in these in these
exosomes
and the RNA world went nuts people loved
it it's a viral component and even the
NIH Common Fund threw money at it as
someone once said that was as close as
the NIH could come to a genome and so
that's where a lot of money went that's
where a lot of interest is gone you can
see over here that every conceivable and
some not so conceivable RNAs including
miscellaneous RNAs show up in these
things have been identified in these
vesicles and my take on that is if you
identify an RNA throw a letter or two
letters three letters in front of it
you've got a publication there's also
some DNA in there
but as far as the rnas go the one thing
I would really like to do is identify
something and call it RNA RNA and thus
cause an existential crisis they will
love that trust me so where do these
things come from and where they end up
well cells make them but they end up in
bio fluids and this is how they get
transported from one place to another
this is where we will find them in the
media from cell lines we'll find them in
blood
we'll find them in urine we'll find them
in saliva other places would include
synovial fluid bronchoalveolar fluid
serial spinal fluid semen breast milk
things like that and especially in the
tears of scientists after they get their
grants rejected very loaded with
exosomes
one thing that I should point out is the
cryo-electron microscopy area has become
very big obviously people winning Nobel
prizes for this compared to what we see
these usually flat squish things that
look like red blood cells have been run
over by a truck the amount of detail and
information in the cryo-electron
microscopy is just extraordinary and I
think this is going to be a huge benefit
for us to start understanding the the
external structures of these as opposed
to just seeing them as flat circles so
if these things leave the cells and end
up in the bio fluids where do they go
next well they can go into your liver
your spleen your kidneys you can urinate
them away you can poop them away they
can get degraded in various places but
they also run into other cells either
nearby or far away as I kind of
mentioned any mechanism that you can
think of to have these internalized
whether it's directly fusing with the
membrane and just allowing the contents
to enter inside or any form of
endocytosis whether it's involved
clathrin or not caviola nor not receptor
mediated endocytosis there's another one
any way you can think of to get
something inside a cell is a way that a
vesicle can get inside a cell what
happens after that is not so clear they
may be degraded they may be stimulatory
they may be able to promote things such
as the delivery of these RNA
so what happens after that is a little
unclear except we watch for the
responses of the self and that's sort of
how we spent most of our time from now
harness throwing exorcisms on cells and
asking what are those cells do so we
view them as information packets ways to
talk so let's can talk to each other
nearby far away and have influences that
are probably seemingly greater than them
you would have just had cell-cell
contact especially with those cells
can't be in contact now as I mentioned
at the start I was kind of asked to put
this in the context of the immune system
and I in a paper to put out some time
ago was asked to do the same thing and
say show me the immune system in one
slide so that's what this was about the
immune system at the most basic level
consists essentially of things that we
would call innate respond ourselves
excuse me these are cells that would are
primed to go after something when
something goes wrong so you get a
bacterial infection there they're a
viral infection there they're on the
other end of this the adaptive side of
things gets a little more specific it
says I need to find a particular antigen
basically to go after and that can
include things and antibodies and in T
cells the link between them our antigen
presenting cells these are things that
recognize problems in the sort of an
inflammation activity and then telling
the adaptive immune system something has
gone wrong we need to fix that so the
cells we'll be focusing on in this case
will be B cells T cells and NK cells for
pretty much the rest of the talk in that
sense the concept of immune surveillance
goes back to the 1950s actually so
Calvin I'm sorry I'm MacFarlane Burnet
and Lois Thomas were the big purveyors
of this and our understanding of how
this works has changed over time but the
basic concept is the same the idea that
neoplasia is perhaps common but cancer
itself relatively speaking is rare so
there must be some sort of immune
mechanisms that look for things going
wrong and then try to stop it before
before it gets out of hand and that's
considered the beta form of immune
surveillance so we presume this works
and keeps cancer out of our bodies most
of the time but obviously things change
and that's where the immune failure
comes in
we know that tumors can actually
literally fight the immune system by
throwing out particular cytokines
putting up barriers it's essentially
attacking the immune system so there
there's an outright battle going on in
that case tumors also can hide from the
immune system they can cloak themselves
in proteins that look normal they can
cloak themselves in other normal cells
and there are particular molecules that
the immune cells look for to recognize
what's going on inside another cell
tumors will actually downgrade those and
try to get rid of them so they appear
basically invisible to the immune system
and then eventually the immune system
begins to ignore the tumors and perhaps
suppresses itself which only allows the
tumors obviously to grow essentially
unstopped by the immune response so as I
had mentioned before and since yet
another one those gorgeous drawings the
idea that these little vesicles look
like tiny portions of the cell little
cellular surrogates I actually wrote
that in a book chapter does that mean we
can use them does it mean we can use
them for instance as biomarkers if the
cell is sick and the releasing vesicles
and we can identify essentially
implications in the the vesicles that's
suggesting that there is cell spit them
out what is sick that can be used as a
biomarker to identify a disease on the
other hand it can also be used as
vaccines in the in a tumor setting these
are little antigen Laden fat balls that
get spit out of them they're just loaded
with antigens we could be able to use
them to provoke an immune response
against the tumor and as it turns out
they're also loaded with immune
suppressed molecules so it becomes a
question of are they useful or are they
not useful and how can we determine this
and what is this dichotomy so let's go
to the vaccine side of things and
oftentimes when you hear that the term
tumor x is ohm it's called tex and this
will pop up a little bit later what's on
text texas all sorts of cool things on
the inside of the the x's
there are presumably antigens antigenic
materials mutated proteins that come
from the tumor that could be recognized
as not self if that's what the immune
system sees also heat shock proteins as
I kind of mentioned before my vaccine
career got started with these things we
understand that they carry in little
pieces little peptides of the tumor
proteome and if those are mutated those
are nicely presented by the immune
system to from from the antigen
presenting cells to the t-cells to start
driving mean responses on the surface of
these things these heat shock proteins
and also things like the high mobility
group proteins are seen as danger
signals that they're released outside
the cell and the tumor can also
literally put out things for the major
histocompatibility complex molecules
that have peptides bound to them so if
that's what's going on and this runs
into a tumor or I'm sorry it runs into a
dendritic cell there are several things
that can happen that internalization
process that I talked about before and
that occurs it can release directly to
the inside and this forms what is kind
of the the sort of black box of antigen
processing so these now these proteins
are now released into the dendritic cell
and they can take them up chop them into
pieces and end up presenting the little
peptides of those on what we call major
histocompatibility complex molecules one
and two these talk to different cell
types the MHC one talks to cd8 t-cells
season of the killer T cells um C D MHC
2 talks to the cd4 positive T cells and
these are called the helper T cells
now the stimulatory effects of these say
from the heat shock proteins or the HM
gb1 excuse me again will actually prompt
the T cell or the dendritic cell rather
to coat make co-stimulatory molecules so
these are things that poke and prod the
T so once that T cell of Destiny with a
t-cell receptor recognizes a peptide
antigen it can now get stimulated by the
dendritic cell to go run out into the
periphery reproduce and go seek out
offending cells that are displaying the
wrong molecules basically antigenic
things out on their services and as I
kind of mentioned most of the time
we expect that the vesicles get
internalized and released but sometimes
the vesicles can just Park on the cell
surface the dendritic cell surface and
essentially act as extensions of the
membrane trigger these these immune
responses so that's that's the goal of
the the concept here is that these
vesicles contain antigen but they also
contain stimulation and that prompts
these antigen presenting cells to get
wound up present antigen to t-cells and
get them wound up and have them go out
to the periphery and chase down the
things that are wrong send in the
cavalry cure cancer and that's what
we're after there I should also point
out that they affect the natural killer
cells the in case cells in multiple ways
so the they often will display these
these vesicles will display things like
mechanic McKay in McBee and then drill
Xcel exosomes so she called X notice how
clever we are Tex and X put out things
called
DL bp1 binding protein 1 as well as
aisle 15 receptor alpha which literally
hands off aisle 15 to the aisle 15
receptor beta and gamma and then the
heat shock proteins that are outside can
actually stimulate an a surface receptor
called CD 94 all of these things won't
get the natural killer cell roundup that
releases grand x so these are basically
bags of proteases that are going to go
on punch holes in the neighboring cell
they spit up pro-inflammatory cytokines
TNF alpha interferon gamma they up
regulate receptors for antibodies so if
the cell next to this has an antibody
stuck to it because you're generating an
immune response the FC receptor will
latch onto that and stimulate antibody
dependent cellular cytotoxicity which I
can't see cuz I'm making a mess of my
slide here but in anyway so that wasn't
to start punching out that the
neighboring cell trying to kill it off
as well so that's what the natural
killer cells will do now we showed in
this particular paper that t-cell and
b-cell responses were pretty potent and
as a vaccine when you use these things
so we weeds had mouse models here can't
draw
so this is this particular brain tumor
mouse model and if we if we vaccinated
mice wit that we didn't vaccinate mice
to MERS grew if we did vaccinate my
tumors didn't grow well as there's one
in every crowd that one
if those mice don't grow tumor as they
tend to survive so we saw enhanced
survival for these things over time as
well now this was done in a prophylactic
setting where we were able to give the
vaccine ahead of time as it turns out
that if you don't do that if you do in
what's called a therapeutic setting
implant the tumor first and then try to
treat and this is a very stringent model
was difficult we didn't see these
responses so we had great responses in
the inmates context of no tumor until
you tried to give it a tumor so
protectively but not it wasn't useful in
a therapeutic setting this was kind of
disturbing what we've we realize first
of all the T cells the B cells are very
important we didn't study the NK cells
but the idea then was well we've got
this great idea well stimulate the
stimulators will affect the effectors we
will write grants that didn't go so well
the National Cancer Institute basically
told us that no it's all about immune
suppression and despite all of these
data and all of these papers that you
see here you're just wrong so the
pendulum had swung the other way we were
now seeing these these tumor vesicles as
immune suppressive and that meant we
kind of had to change gears but also
barring we still would bear in mind that
they were good vaccines what's the
difference between the vaccine potential
the stimulatory potential and the
suppressant potential so what are these
suppressive effects well not only do the
tumors make you know the the the good
things we want to see the antigens the
HSP stuff like that they also put out
things like the RNAs we don't know a lot
about what these do but presumably some
of them will be suppressive to receptor
cells like t-cells as far as the there
are these exonucleases CD 39 CD 73
t-cells love ATP these things eat ATP
and converted to adenosine T cells hate
adenosine so that's a rough one there's
a molecule called fast ligand that's
present on a lot of tumors and ends up
therefore present on their exosomes it's
known to interact with the fast receptor
this ends up killing these cells of
literally killing those t-cells it's a
death receptor and it's just it's not a
pretty sight so we were going to move on
from that other things that you may have
heard of over over time because they're
getting more and more famous are things
like the program death ligand one which
can be on the tumor and therefore is on
exosomes it interacts with programmed F
one ligand receptor rather on the T
cells and essentially disables them
transforming growth factor beta is also
present on the surface of these things
in a variety of forms sometimes
completely latent sometimes completely
active that's able to take t-cells and
essentially turn them into regulatory
t-cells so regulatory t-cells are the
the no-fun police of the immune system
these are very potent cells in terms of
shutting off activated responses as well
as shutting off the initial signaling
that goes through dendritic cells are
very potent at that on the b-cell side
so these surface antigens are very good
for instance we learned that they make
some remarkable antibodies in in
recipient cells but unfortunately those
antigens can also titrate out those hand
bodies that may be either generated by
the host or things we actually uses as
therapeutics and obviously this reduces
the ability of the the immune system to
use the antibodies against the tumor
another aspect of these things is they
may complement receptor which takes
complement out of the equation and
therefore reduces complement dependent
sunsh toxicity some of these danger
signals if overused will end up making
regulatory b-cells so these are kind of
like the the no-fun police of the b-cell
system so think of them as these these
molecules are on the surfaces of the
cells they can stimulate that they can
also suppress and I think that's what we
need to understand that the main
difference is on them as far as the
natural killer cells go those same
proteins that were very good at at
binding receptors and stimulating than
the NK cells such as the NK gd2 ligand
and the CD 94 ligand those are also the
same ones that will end up causing them
to to go
way so it will cause the ink a cell to
pull those out and that's part of the
safety mechanism right it's part of
keeping the incase cell from going crazy
and killing everything it sees because
it doesn't really have that the level of
specificity that the t-cells do in
addition other suppressive moieties on
these exosomes such as tgf-beta can
actually then slow down and incapacitate
the national killer cell and essentially
taking that out of the system so the
idea being that the exosomes may look
like bits of tumor but if they look like
too much of the tumor the t-cell will
shoot itself off so they can appear to
be decoys as well as capable of
disseminating the natural killer cells
so we have this dichotomy there's
yin-yang this double-edged sword of
exosomes as stimulators of the system
but also as repressors of the system so
what is this dichotomy and we had come
up with the idea of that text so cancer
exosomes texts in terms of context we
wrote an entire paper built around that
title the issue that you're going to see
here though is that I would suggest as
who sees them first if the
antigen-presenting cells see them and
they would in a vaccine setting where
you're giving something usually
intradermally or subcutaneously it's
going to encounter the the cells that's
going to encounter called Langerhans
cells and they are sort of the dendritic
cells of the skin since they've not been
suppressed in any way they're going to
find these stimulatory they're going to
find antigens are going to promote
t-cell responses on the other hand it's
the tumor cells secreting them and to
get into the bloodstream the cells that
the the exosomes will encounter are
going to be the t-cells and possibly
monocytes as well and these will have
essentially d stimulatory or suppressive
effects as the monocytes get turned into
things called myeloid derived suppressor
cells they're suppressor built right in
and add those secrete molecules that
will deflate the immune system and as I
mentioned before the t-cells are being
turned off as well so who sees it when
and how is probably the critical aspect
of what determines whether you've got a
vaccine quality or a suppressive quality
now we've done some studies on this
where we in brain tumor cells so these
are cells grown in what we call
Speirs it doesn't really matter to most
of you but it's really cool for the
brain tumor people we take the exosomes
from that and threw them on lymphocytes
I said what what happens to the
lymphocytes what we noticed was that
there was a dysregulated signaling that
occurred and it was kind of disturbing
and what it led to because it suggested
that the cells would be inactivated but
would still proliferate and that's kind
of counterintuitive to what most people
think of immune responses for T cells in
particular usually their proliferation
is indicative of their stimulation but
we saw they lost their pro-inflammatory
cytokines and made anti inflammatory
cytokines and then they also stopped
moving they just didn't crawl the way
they should from an immune perspective
from from an immune suppressants
perspective that's kind of a novel form
of immune suppression if the t-cells
can't get to the tumor or can't enter it
they're not going to cause any damage so
we saw this we published us awhile back
and I've referred to it as the turning
t-cells into teenagers because they're
living in your basement they're eating
you out of house and home and they're
not doing a damn thing so if you've got
kids you probably understand that better
than most so that's my concept of what
goes on it's not necessarily wiping out
the t-cells but just making them
ineffective and metabolically kind of
useless because they're they're going to
mess with you so following up on these
questions one thing we mentioned before
didn't work that's not showing the way I
thought it would so we've also done some
work where we've looked at what happens
I've got our thing pulled on my screen
it won't go away there we go we have not
I'm not going to talk about this but
when immune when 20 cells I'm sorry when
tumor cells throw exosomes back on
themselves they get wound up and make
all sorts of strange signalling
arrangements that they just shouldn't be
doing so but I'm not going to talk about
that we don't have time but I will talk
about the idea that tumor vesicles will
tell astrocytes brain tumor vesicles
will tell astrocytes that they want to
change you become gangsta wannabes and
I'm sure all you're familiar with the
cult film pup fiction that's pub fiction
by the way so what are astrocytes I am
NOT a neuroscientist by any stretch of
the imagination which is amazing to work
in a brain tumor field they are sort of
the
glue of the brain these are structurally
very important they're very supportive
not just structurally but also
metabolically and and with Parekh and
secretions for the neurons and for the
vasculature they kind of hold the brain
together so people say you only use 10%
of your brain what they're really saying
is that a lot of it is actually
structural support from the brain tumor
world this is about as close as we get
to a true glioma microenvironment we
don't have the cancer associated
fibroblast we don't have the cancer
associated adipocytes that would go
along with this whoops what did I just
do to the screen okay there we go sorry
about that hit the wrong button alright
and so consequently I'm going to call
them the glioma microenvironment for
whatever that's worth these are some
lovely slides from people who actually
know how to make really good pictures
showing for instance the the interaction
of astrocytes with a vasculature the
interaction of astrocytes these these
these stellate stringy cells with with
the neurons and here's a nice drawing of
that those these feet that are necessary
to hold the blood vessels together to
keep the axon stable so that's what the
the the astrocytes tend to do at a
physical level so we did the same sort
of experiment I just described where we
take brain tumor cells and grow them and
culture and then collect their exosomes
and then throw them on on astrocytes
then ask what happens what we saw was
that the the astrocytes these are normal
astrocytes spit out an extraordinary
cytokine milieu they develop these crazy
queueing pathways that were very
disturbing and this led to inappropriate
growth and migration so those are going
to be the the main take-home messages
from the last part of this talk you're
required by law if you're into the
exposome or extra so Invesco Field to
show your purification system so here's
ours you can see it's mostly a bunch of
of pure Center irrigations
and filtrations and what we get out of
that are vesicles these are cells over
here by the way these are not the
vesicles these are the cells grown as
neurospheres what we will see though is
that using something called nano
particle tracking analysis we can
actually get sizes on these things we
can actually get concentrations of them
as well
so these are just vesicles from these
particular cells they're number ways
to do this so those are just
characterizations of these we've also
shown that they have all the biochemical
properties in terms of molecules that
they're supposed to have using these
arrays as well so though there is your
there's your exosome purification these
are other methods most of them involve
forms of centrifugation we also have
forms of electron microscopy atomic
force microscopy all these sorts of
things to characterize them as well as
the biochemical and cell biological ways
to do that the one thing I will point
out is that no matter what you do no one
else is gonna like it this is kind of
amazing in the field how only my way is
a way to do it we're trying to come up
with a uniform method for these but I
think it's going to be difficult because
the downstream first of all the upstream
where do we get these do they come from
URI do they come from ascites fluid you
can't start the same way and depending
on what your end assay as you can't
necessarily finish the same way so we're
still engaged and how do we fight the
sort of thing so what we've done is ask
questions about what happens to the
astrocytes like I said when we throw X's
ohms on them from tumors and they
migrate so if we if we take the
astrocytes growing in a dish and we
scrape a needle across into the
scratch-and-sniff assay and we throw X's
ohms on those those X's will cause the
astrocytes to fill the gap faster and
way more efficiently so that it's as if
the tumor is calling out to the
astrocytes to come to it come to the
holes well why would it do that it's
because the astrocytes then essentially
feed the tumor they put out this
extraordinary cytokine array and this is
a heat map so what you're seeing down
here on this side is at zero so it's
kind of cool what you're seeing up here
at 24 hours is very very hot and the
molecules I've outlined are things that
are interested in interesting - brain
tumor people's you don't need to get too
buried in that but just notice that that
everything is turned to hunt seemingly
interleukins fibroblast growth factors
regular growth factors all sorts of
things that are just going to be yummy
as far as the tumor is concerned and
we've chunked all that information into
some of these bio a bio pathway he
analyzes in this case ingenuity pathway
analysis and it shows us it looks like
an inflammatory response I would agree
with that it looks like cancer cell cell
signaling and cell migration these
things should be
and we suspect that's undoubtedly the
case but as far as the the feeding the
beast aspect of it we we took the
exosomes from tumour cells through the
moms and astrocytes let the astrocytes
percolate that for a while then it
hasn't collect that media and then we
put it back on the tumor cells that
spent media the condition median said
you grow faster and the GBM cells do
grow faster the tumor cells grow faster
and this is saying a lot because these
cells grow very fast as it is so back
again to the idea that were 80 the the
astrocytes end up aiding and abetting
the tumor when they get in contact with
these with these tumor astrocyte or with
these tumor vesicles and when we look at
a couple of signaling pathways to get
turned on there we see Eric and akt
are sort of that hubs of that which
probably just ask a question what goes
on with the signaling so we delved into
that as well with a signaling array this
is a phospho protein array so what
you're seeing here are phosphorylated
things so you see early on and a low
concentrations not much is happening but
as time progresses and as we throw more
and more exosomes on we see dramatic
changes in a lot of these signaling
molecules including the urks
the stats the a katie's these all seem
to get turned on and I looked at that
and I thought it looks a lot like a ture
signaling profile and I wasn't alone in
that we chunked it into the ingenuity
pathway analysis it told us the same
thing so bear in mind these are
astrocytes that now look like they have
it that they have cancer is what it
amounts to they're they have cell death
and survival mechanisms in place and
they in theory would look like a tumor
that was very disturbing to us and the
other thing we found out is that if we
take these various pathways and pile
them on top of each other
we find a katie's the hub the very
center of all of that and this is the
driver of this giant hairball of stuff
which is very common in a lot of cancers
in particular in gliomas we know that
many pathways are a KT a KT driven what
really disturbed us though was that if
these things do these astrocytes think
there are cancer and we grew them in
something called soft auger this is a
way to essentially defined transformed
cells so it's your cells growing soft
Aughra there in time and generally they
don't they don't like to grow and
they're not adherent but we saw that
actually occur that's a high
doses of vesicles so it looks like the
astrocytes really do think they're a
tumor at least in and this they kind of
a say now we've done most of our assays
based on arrays and things like where we
chose what questions to ask we wanted to
broaden this to a little less biased
form and so we're asking about what is
the transcript on doing so from that
transcriptome we're gonna have
astrocytes doing nothing but we're going
to have astrocytes that were incubated
with tumor exosomes and we're going to
have astrocytes that are incubated with
epithelial cell axes all normal cell
exosomes and then we extract RNA from
everything and then run it on a on a on
a cool little array called the Clarion
one this one has a bunch transcript so
we get a lot of data out of it why do we
say for instance to do that as opposed
to RNA seek and this began as a student
projects we couldn't spend tons and tons
of time waiting for the bioinformatics
we could kind of do this ourselves also
these are normal cells they shouldn't be
full of mutation so we didn't really
need to sequence that kind of thing you
care about that and we didn't really
think about the non-coding RNAs but
we're beginning to do that now because
it's becoming annoying so this is
preliminary data do not buy or sell
stocks on this basis and once again it
helps to be able to avoid your biome
from Addison's from there and not
terribly helpful and very demanding
instead so here's this typical sort of
representation of that things that are
falling off the line here off the
diagonal are going to be things that we
care about that are highly expressed for
instance on the tumor side so where the
astrocytes received tumor vesicles were
seeing what's happening up here in that
corner if we took that information and
chunked it once again into ingenuity
pathway analysis we see a number of
things pop up that was might have been
not surprised and such as interferon
signalling but the fact that they seem
to think they were infected we seem to
see these inflammatory and and anti
pathogen tails coming up so we had to
ask well is that actually going on here
so once again these responses are kind
of built into the system you see a lot
of here fear on you tend to see this and
the network's going to show up being
inflammatory and antimicrobial but
molecules we saw every one of these is
either induced by interferon induces
interferon or is responding to
interferon in one way or another so when
we look at the the next step and that
just some western blotting of some of
those we've done more and I couldn't
manage to get it into this talking time
things called OAS illegal adenylate
synthase such as these - we actually
have one for a s 2 as well goes up for
one not so much for 3 definitely goes up
for 2 like I said not shown and then
others glial February acidic proteins so
as astrocytes they make this but they
also tend to over express that if they
get stressed or crazed and we see this
in brain tumors but usually it's because
of what we call the glial scar a form of
gliosis is occurring because you have a
physical structure crashing through the
astrocytes in this case it's just
exosomes
causing this up regulation of the G fab
protein which is once again since since
suspecting that we've got wild stresses
going on so we saw that a lot of the
interferon cygwin that i kind of
mentioned before we see interferon gamma
and but in this case we didn't really
see much we didn't know about the the
type 1 interferons alpha and beta we
knew that stat got turned on stat 1 we
didn't know anything about stat - but
everybody down here is an interferon
responding molecule either will further
drive more interferon or
reacts with it so looking further into
that like I said we knew about the gamma
interferon we didn't really know about
the type 1 so we did those assays as
well and what we can see here is that
look at this one's nice it gave us both
type 1 2 & 3 in some cases not all of
them interferon alpha does go up
interferon beta does go up so these are
being spit out of astrocytes when they
receive brain tumor exosomes you throw a
brain tumor exosomes on them they will
make they will then make these cytokines
the only one that occurs no matter what
kind of extra zooms you throw on it is
il-6 and we're interested in that as
well but there are forms of interferon I
didn't even know existed I didn't know
that there was an apparent lambda and
interferon Omega what are these things
so all of these sort of super responses
in an interferon mechanism seem to be
turned on very very pro-inflammatory the
concept pain that this looks like a
viral infection it's as if the tumor
cells themselves feel like they have
sorry the the astrocytes feel like
they've had a viral infection where that
come from well as I mentioned when we
first saw this illegal adenylate
synthase molecule pop up I thought well
that's an enzyme nice but it's not
actually a cool enzyme it it synthesizes
2 prime 5 prime illegal a which
activates RNA cell RNA Seldon cleaves
double-stranded RNA here in here and
then these bits of double-stranded RNA
are very stimulatory towards things
called rig-i and MDA 5 indeed i didn't
show we saw rig i goes way up as well
this is part of what we would call the
the NH response system inside the cell
so this triggers a lot of activity at
the mitochondria to start doing things
and in the end you end up making more
and more interferon so the whole
interferon story comes back to this
again where do these double-stranded
RNAs come from probably the exosomes
and I should also point out that usually
these RNAs have strange modifications to
them usually because of being degraded
so that may be the difference between
the tumor vesicles and the normal
vesicles is that the RNA is kind of
battered inside the tumor vesicles or
there's just more of it and that will
lead to the this whole this whole
process of acting like you've got a
viral infection throw out interferon try
to save the day so once again the idea
that we treat tumor we take two more X's
ohm's throw them on normal astrocytes
and ask what happens so the cells grow
inappropriately they migrate in ways
they probably shouldn't so come to the
dark side the cytokine soup feeds the
beast and the crazy signaling suggest to
the astrocytes that they might be a
tumor and that is a in terms of say a
recurrent tumor setting so what happens
in your average going on the treatment
is we we cut it out we irradiated and
then we throw chemotherapeutics at you
so it's astrocytes left-behind have been
receiving basically getting hit by tumor
exosomes for a long period of time
they may be changed and that's what
we're trying to say so exosomes in
general from tumors are going to be used
to benefit the tumor that's pretty much
all there is to it even though I tried
to say that we might be able to use them
in an immune setting they're more likely
in by the time we find the tumor to be
immune suppressive and this can happen
to the tumor itself can happen to the
immune cells can bother the neighbors
the normal neighbors and in that
environment the astrocytes are going to
crawl in response to the tumor exosomes
the signaling pathways are going to
change inside the astrocytes reminiscent
of the tumor itself the astrocytes are
going to spew things out aid and abet
the tumor in its growth which is the
last thing we really need and they will
turn all this this amazingly
inflammatory interferon response which
I'm not sure what that means we're
trying to hack into that a little bit
further and the question I would suggest
or have is that these are astrocytes or
a mutation away from perhaps actually
becoming truly cancerous so if we peel
off that hairball down one layer what we
see the next the next sort of big node
down is p53 this molecule is mutated in
about a third to half of high-grade
gliomas and we we treat these glands
remember with we fry the resection
cavity with radiation and then we
essentially Bayview in a DNA damaging
agent so I would suggest that if you've
got a mute if you drive a mutation in
those astrocytes and you then pound it
or have it pounded pre it preemptively
with tumor exosomes it may be a short
step to becoming an actual tumor so what
do we do about this well I've kind of
mentioned the akt story this has been a
therapeutic target forever and it's just
not gone well in many cases because the
blood brain barrier issue for brain
tumors it's just a hard thing to treat
pediatric cases they've tried a couple
of things and what they found mostly
toxicities and there are other sort of
experimental ones out on the market so
hopefully we can maybe get through a
going after a Katey I'm not going to
hold my breath on that but what about
inflammation control what if we started
saying after we cut the tumor out maybe
we should start working on trying to
keep inflammation down inside that brain
area we know that there are antibodies
used against interferons and against the
receptors that can be that have been
used in multiple sclerosis and these are
drugs that could be repurposed to target
the stats but also we know that this
could also perhaps be controlled by
non-steroidal anti-inflammatories was
very tolerant curcumin so take your
nonsteroidals drink your wine and and be
sure to eat spicy foods maybe this will
help control that inflammation at least
at the area of the tumor back to the
immune thing so what what's going on
with that now well we know that and many
of you probably know that on the market
right now is the the big idea so to use
checkpoint inhibitors block those things
that block the suppression and this can
come in multiple forms things that
targets specific molecules things that
target the regulatory t-cells and a
number of these have made it into
clinical trials and have actually made
it into FDA approval for a number of
tumors so it looks like the concept of
suppressing the suppressors has been
very important but what that also
implies is that you have a batch of
t-cells out there that haven't truly
been stimulated and could respond if you
just take the breaks off and I think
that's going to be the next thing is
taking the breaks off you block what you
have to block whether it's on the
t-cells or it's on the tumor and then
you allow the responses to occur one
must be careful with this because if you
take off too many of the breaks you have
a number of auto reactive t-cells just
hanging around that won't attack your
systems and these have been the major
toxicities we've seen with these
particular therapy s so control a tumor
by releasing your immune system and no
cats were harmed in the making of this
particular production how does this work
in a antibody level because those are
the action we call them drugs are
usually antibodies what we have as I
kind of mentioned the antigen presenting
cells stimulates the t-cell with a with
the MHC complex as well as these
co-stimulatory molecules the t-cell and
response gets wound up but also sticks
out a molecule to say okay in case I
need a kill switch here it is in case I
lose control here's that so this could
be the that's that leads to the
inhibitory aspect of it where the the
antigen presenting cell has the PD one
ligand whereas the T cell has the PD one
after that we'll turn it off and
deactivate it this strategy is to use
antibodies against one or both of those
and therefore keep that response on and
keep it from being turned off tumors do
this as well tumors have PD one ligand
they present and that's what causes the
t-cell to attack but if they present if
they have PD one ligand they can also
stimulate the PD one receptor on the T
cells and effectively inhibit that so
once again using the antibodies to block
those on both sides of the coin it seems
to be a very popular terrip utak
approach right now and you're gonna see
a lot of that in the future it is a
multi-billion dollar industry so Gideon
know that if you can alright to wrap
things up because I think I've gone a
long time I just want to point out that
some collaborators are better than
others Jose Cuervo disaster cat and
kitchen which are not necessarily good
ones but Tom answered okie is also the
people who are truly responsible for
this Justin hell wanker was now a med
student he was instrumental and doing a
lot of the work here Solomon who she is
now a resident at Mayo he was the one
behind the astrocytes story jamie
married each leg and tests that had been
working with us for a long time they're
now and some of them are in med school
Yasmina started most of the proteomic
work that i didn't talk about my two
bosses Kevin and Aviva and I want to
thank Jen Maitland for keeping us out of
IRB jail and I want to thank the money
that's obviously very important so I
want to thank them and thank all of you
and as it turns out I'm not actually if
you have questions you should be able to
email me what I would suggest you do is
I don't often respond to emails because
I forget very quickly so keep emailing
me don't be afraid to keep emailing me
I'll eventually get back to you so I
want to thank you for that and thank you
for for letting me be a part of this
thank you dr. grey nurse for that
informative presentation we will now
start to lock you in a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your questions into the box that appears
on your screen and click on the send
button well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question is do brain
tumor actually homes end up in the blood
stream yes they do I didn't mention this
very much about the
the biomarker field that is exploding
around these things so the term liquid
biopsy is often used the idea being that
if we can pull say blood out of somebody
and then analyze components of the blood
and say oh you have a tumor or your
tumor has these mutations or you have
this disease or that disease we think of
these things as soluble molecules but it
turns out that probably a lot of that is
actually floating in these vesicle forms
so people are using proteins but you've
heard that but they're especially
turning to the RNAs because those can be
amplified so the question from a brain
tumor perspective is can to get across
the blood-brain barrier and it appears
that they can and in terms both ways not
just exiting the brain but getting into
the brain so yes they they do get out we
identified them years ago Johann Skog
and and in under break fields group did
this years ago as well so we know that
they're out there part of the issue with
the brain initially the brain tumor
initially is that it kind of leaves
holes in there so things can escape the
blood-brain barrier but but when you
remove the tumor that tends to heal and
yet these vesicles still manage to get
out so those are evident those are
present and we can use those we hope we
can use those as biomarkers of
therapeutics in this case do we see
changes in the micro vesicle type and
content and numbers and is it responding
to therapies that work whether it use
them to treat the patients thank you for
that answer it looks like we have time
for one more question our next question
is how can exosomes be used as vaccines
at a practical level that's an
interesting question generally speaking
these come from cell line sources at
least most of the academic studies and
that means you've got the cell lines
available and that's not going to
necessarily be the case from a
personalized perspective say from a
patient the areas where we've managed to
get them in large quantities would be
from cancers that generate like a
sides-- fluid we're able to obtain large
volumes of liquid from from the
patient's stomach basically and those
are also chock-full of extras ohm's
those have been used in clinical trials
that's from the that's from the tumor
side of things people have also used
exosomes from dendritic cells as
vaccines so the idea is you take
patience dendritic cells out of their
blood you grow them in culture you throw
antigens on them one way or another and
then you collect the exosomes that come
off we used to do inject the dendritic
cells back in but there's all sorts of
viability issues freezing issues
activity issues so the idea being that
the you can harvest the vesicles from
the dendritic cells themselves and use
those as vaccines those are sort of the
two ways we think of that as we start
developing better bioreactor type growth
phenomenon for these and as we start to
realize that maybe you don't have to
have a personalized vaccine we could
have more general antigen sort of loaded
into that we may be able to actually
engineer these things and that's sort of
the state of the art right now I would
like to once again thank dr. Michael
Greiner for his presentation I would
also like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through January
2017 you will receive an email from
Lavery letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcements with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye